Joe and Gina Mastretta bought this
potted Scotch pine 34 years ago when it
was about 3 feet tall it looks different
every year some years are good some
years are not this that you happen to
catch on a really good year in 1983 it
was so small it could only hold one
string of Lights and when the holiday
was over out it went not to the trash or
recycling bin but to a new year-round
home in the yard it's got its own shape
it's got its own character but it's
still growing a few years later Joe and
Gina had two little boys who grew to
love Christmas morning around their tiny
tree now 27 and 31 it's the only
Christmas tree Michael and Joseph have
ever known if someone is more
traditional for a triangular tree that's
great but it's really what the tree
represents it's like people you know as
good years bad years but you know even
when we thought it wasn't going to make
it they were like you can't get rid of
this tree dad you know this is our tree
while it looks more like a Christmas
Bush with a little TLC it continues to
thrive I enjoy trimming it I go out
there I spend a little time with it i
how you doing today you're doing good
don't worry I'm gonna clean you up a
sucker so the tree talked about
he's repotted the tree four times it
even survived a fire the home's front
door had to be doubled in size so the
nearly 300 pound tree can still be
rolled in I mean there is no perfect
life there is no perfect tree we like it
that way and the ornaments that we put
on it are not perfectly put in the
perfect spot but they mean something to
us so these are birds from my mom's tree
1940 we have lake tahoe this one Michael
made in kindergarten the tree is a time
capsule of their lives it was here when
Gina's parents were alive and shared the
holidays with them it was here when
Michael was diagnosed with leukemia at
the age of 13 and five years later when
he went into remission it's really
family member you bring in and going
okay it's time for you now come on I've
taken care of you the whole year now now
it's your turn
show time it definitely represents
tradition
it brings back memories and it will
continue to be here as the family makes
new memories after all the Scotch pine
can well be around for another hundred
years there's so many people that have
touched this our lives and they've been
part of that tree we're getting older
and the tree is getting older with us
and you know it's growing with us for
CBS this morning Saturday midday of
yo-yo Los Angeles I love this story like
people it has good years it has bad
years exactly and it is what a tree
should be yeah exactly family's life all
wrapped up in it